welcome to this video no I'm sorry this
is some slightly sore throat okay this
is cool first game of a session no kind
of warm up game and the first one is
already against Oleg us my old favorite
opponent the guy is playing every
position on time no matter what and he's
got a really low rating form yeah
considering what he usually has okay I'm
i played the london system wanted to get
a simple position try to to play
relatively quickly yeah he's going to
play five but this is also quite a
simplification okay it was taking okay i
can also play efore as this may be an
idea yeah that's not fall too far behind
on the clock this guy's just the most
wonderful player I know with regards to
time so just try to be quick to not
spend too much time
yeah it's a relatively open position if
i take my hippity threads rock the aid
so what's hands not to take care let's
just do that if you place the rook c8
i'm going to play quincy one so didn't
do that so Luke see one maybe intend no
bit of age seven yeah it's about equal
my guess Queen B 6 I now go Bishop b3
this is a good position for the bishop
maybe why does slightly more comfortable
Quincy to Quincy seven the same as an
idea I'm slightly more comfortable now
because of the b3 bishop okay he's
immediately going to neutralize that k
let's let's take he's attacking here on
a tomb
okay if he goes queen 82 and play okay
one regressor should be an active
position for me of course it's very dry
but this is normal here climates
completely okay to trade down everything
to some kind of dead end game and then
play on time okay really making a
conscious effort not to fall too far
behind k rook takes is going to check
here so i probably should take with the
the night so
yeah look see two hmm it's a potential
idea
and looky eight might be my beep in that
can be can be a problem yeah but ok
let's let's play actively he cannot keep
the shack pinned all the time he can't
play rook see one King everyone but is
he always has be seven to worry about
they don't really believe that yeah
that's an interesting try so just
activate with 93 or not
yeah well I can I can play that one okay
look see 10 hmm yeah some tricky
business he's gained slide something
it's not really not really a big problem
ah this is a bad move rookie 7 that he's
got night see for coming yeah this is
just very bad play what I did that okay
maybe night be 695 is still ok maybe but
I allowed far too much check I think
wasn't necessary at all
still might be 695 how are you going to
protect to protect b7 not at all check
yeah this is very often the problem try
you try not to for 25 yard on the clock
as is going to play every position on
time and then you sometimes put yourself
into trouble I shouldn't really have a
lot to serve this end game I think it's
still a draw
I have to break through don't tell me
that's a breakthrough now g5 maybe their
walls
I think I think it really could play g5
Graham are drawn yeah this is the
repetition I thought and maybe I'm
completely wrong but in this position I
think g 5y not g5 I thought this would
wrap I'm after quickie g6 of course the
I a g6 okay this is chad big point okay
yeah then it it really was the draw all
the all the way OPA could win yeah i was
i would idea for was a move that
instantly made me made me doubt king d
three wins here played that very quickly
check king d3s winning not completely
sure at the moment wine yeah okay well
if i go g3 is going to play at five of
care of course and after this he's going
to win win material and the game and if
i go to g3 yeah that's also at five this
type of maneuver yeah this is just to
win night f4 was a terrible move i can
just play something else i mean it's
it's it's really a dead position I keep
this response these prawns protected and
nothing's ever i'm going to happen
but the end game really am but I got I
got into slide trouble here he has some
some some annoyance going rupee eight
this is really a slight problem and
here's something else this is maybe 22
forthcoming I don't know he's very good
at this kind of super dry positions
alright thanks for watching